[Applaus]
[Musik]
in wels platz 14
und ich hätte herrschaften jetzt mal
aufwecken tag war offensichtlich zu spät
hallo dann waren sie bereit mitgebracht
den schnellen und dann kann es schon
losgehen
wir werden nicht viel zeit verlieren
wenn wir das geld überhaupt geräte
leopard 2 auf johansson
dazu sind sieht man ihm sehr gut
der platz wird dann alle schützen sieht
mein platz kann man da drinnen habe den
schützen andere aber den fahrer wird
sagen wir fahren zum ausbildungs täter
die angestellte bei der österreichischen
position was wo sie wissen es gibt ein
paar tabata ließ das fahrerfeld am 14
wir verfügen insgesamt über 56
kampfpanzern ebenso ab wie wir mit einem
hier fahren
der leopard ist noch immer da standard
kampfpanzer in europa haben pause war
der ps wenn man kann ohne den 120 mm
deren eltern zum zweiten von 2002 1500
meter bewegungsgeräte bis zu 80 km h
schnell
das wohl stabilisiert wenn ich jetzt
davon träume panzer fahren oder
verfahren zu werden denn dem handel
natürlich wird genauso kaum was weiß ich
was sage ich hatte fünf schlussmann kann
man bei uns alles werden ein rück nicht
mehr passiert sein kann ist unter den
baggerfahrer werden rechtsschütze laden
schütze und als karl präsenz soldat
zusammen dieselben funktionen möglich
und wer bleiben will kann natürlich zu
panzergranaten fahrzeugs kohl anstalten
jeder
das bundesheer ist ganz besonders stolz
immer auf seinen achten dass nach die
panzerfahrer so stolz wir sind das
schwere mechanisierte rückgrats der
militärischen landesverteidigung wir
schauen dass wir alle anderen staaten
die uns antworten finden unterstützt
neben einmal prinzipiell anlass um mit
den kommentaren posten nicht geben wenn
aber wie wäre es neben bands erfahren
haben dass ich eine ausbildung davor
ich dachte jetzt vollständig urlaub hat
den kaffee
willkommen im ausbildungszentrum am so
genannten hd auspuffanlage turm
das stück ist vorher du gehst jetzt auf
dem platz mit buch deine und damit die
kanone die vorstellung gibt brauchst du
auch auf waffen sicher
fünf minuten kampfzeit einstellung feuer
woher das nicht schlimm was sagst du
jetzt planlos bitte endlich dass der vor
leerer wird der einweisen bitte dich das
einfach einmal einige sehr cool
[Applaus]
wer bereit ja sie wohl zur ausbildung
ist zu ende
wir können das sofort parat
[Musik]
zweiter vorstand service
ok
[Musik]
alle fotos 1 muss der staat genau freien
folge 1 0 dann hebt er zwölf trennung
war schon vater übungsplatz beginnen
indem
[Musik]
das war nicht schlecht das klären wir
waren zu bewegen
rechts ein parcours für die angesteckt
die erst jetzt mal probeweise
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wer ich noch einmal 23 jahre jünger also
18 team eine einheit gefunden war sie
heute alles erlebt habt das war schon
echt total verantwortungsvolle coole
leute extrem gut ausgebildet die einen
unglaublichen job machen und das nicht
nur wichtig gut sondern preisgekrönt gut
als ein halbes jahres beim
österreichischen bundesheer und da ist
es speziell weil sie nämlich ein
internationaler preis welcher das tief
vom juli
ihr wollt die allerbesten herzliche
gratulation tageweise ab dürfen
danke für dich habe ich noch kurz und so
cage und eine kleine aufgabe
sie schauen was noch mal einen cellisten
so was für mich ja ja das ist also das
besondere job für mich speziell für mich
[Musik]